[Music]
[Applause]
the master sword has become one of the
most famous and recognizable swords in
all of fantasy so much so that nintendo
created an entire game devoted to its
backstory it's more than a sword it's an
icon a sacred blade forged in the flames
of the very gods themselves and blessed
with the power to seal darkness it's a
legend that finds its origin in one of
the earliest points in the timeline and
not just the zelda timeline but hours as
well it made its debut all the way back
in the early 90s and since then it's
been wielded by several heroes in the
fight between good and evil particularly
against the ever so persistent king of
evil ganondorf it's a true staple of the
series one that has endured all the way
up to the present day with its most
recent appearance being the latest zelda
epic 2017's breath of the wild then we
saw this
[Music]
if you've only played breath of the wild
this image might not be all that
impactful but for a long time fan of the
series seeing the legendary sword which
has been my companion throughout so many
adventures having been reduced to this
is actually quite shocking we are
experiencing zelda history right here
never before has something like this
happened in spite of the passing of so
many ages and all the abuse it has taken
over the course of its existence the
master sword always held firm sure it
did lose its sacred glow a couple of
times and received some chip damage
during the great calamity but nothing a
few songs and prayers or the flow of
time couldn't fix this time however it
seems like there might not be an easy
way to salvage the situation the
emblematic weapon of legend truly seems
to be on its last legs and at the worst
possible time too for the sequel it's
all but confirmed that this time we'll
be dealing with the real ganondorf as
opposed to yet another one of his
puppets and historically the sword that
seals the darkness has always been a key
element to his downfall without the
decisive blow he won't be weak enough to
be sealed away or maybe even killed
outright with the sword in this
miserable state yet still remaining in
link's possession i think it's safe to
assume that breathtak ii's story will
focus heavily on finding a way to
reverse the damage done to it the
question is how how do you fix well this
well that's what i want to explore today
we'll take a look at the different
aspects that created the master sword
see if these elements are still
accessible in some way in the era of
breath of the wild and how these could
shape the overall story and gameplay of
the highly anticipated sequel at the end
i'll even throw in some alternative
ideas not because i believe that these
will come to fruition quite the opposite
in fact but more as a way to cover as
much ground as possible i guess so let's
take a look at the possibilities to
restore the master sword
[Music]
[Music]
no matter how iconic or legendary at the
end of the day swords are objects and
thus they can be broken however this
doesn't always have to be the end of it
sometimes it can be remade
it has been remade
it can be restored to its former self or
even forged into something new perhaps
something even better but how do you fix
a sword that has no pieces left to put
back together the master sword isn't
just broken or shattered it's been
melted charred eaten away down to its
very core we've seen that given enough
time and under the right circumstances
the sword can magically regenerate
itself just like it did in the 100 years
following the calamity but with almost
half of the blade completely gone this
might be beyond something time can fix
and even if it could the current
predicaments don't exactly give our
heroes a lot of time to spare all things
considered the damage to the master
sword in breath the wild was pretty
surface level and even then it took
close to a century to heal imagine how
long it would take to restore the
devastation seen in the new footage with
ganondorf on the loose it seems like the
only option is to somehow reforge the
master sword or find a suitable
replacement for it before hyrule falls
at the mercy of the demon king of course
there's a level of uncertainty to what
needs to be done in order to restore the
blade simply because we don't know for
sure what kind of state the master sword
is in exactly i mean the physical damage
is evident but it's not clear how much
of its original power still remains
inside as the sacred force of the
goddesses left the sword does it need to
be blessed by hylia all over again does
it require the help of one or more sages
to restore it to its true splendor we
don't know so i'm gonna have to go with
what i think makes the most sense in
terms of game design and story
progression based on what we know about
the game's content right now so let's
say that breathtak 2 is going to be a
big freaking game and that maybe with
the exception of phi the master sword
has been reduced to an empty shell
devoid of any of the elements that once
made up its power what do we need in
order to restore it the circumstances
that led to the creation of the sword
and subsequently upholding its power to
seal the darkness throughout the ages
involves quite a few different factors
first is the power of the gods of
creation din nehru and feror more
specifically the force that stems from
them which is described as the breath of
life itself in skyward sword this force
took on the shape of three sacred flames
each with the color of its corresponding
goddess red blue and green which
represents power wisdom and courage
respectively when all three forces are
combined the blade is imbued with a
sacred white light that demons are said
to revile also referred to as a divine
light oh and fun fact if you mix red
blue and green light you get white light
so props to nintendo for sticking to the
laws of physics second is goddess hylia
who is said to have created the sword
that would serve as the basis for the
master sword as well as giving life to
phi the spirit who dwells within it
we'll get into fire and demise in a
later section after dousing the sword in
the sacred flames it already became
known as the master sword but in order
to defeat demise it needed one final
push after zelda completes her
transformation into the mortal
incarnation of hylia her final blessing
created the true master sword as we know
it and with it the ability to slay even
the most powerful demons who oppose the
gods lastly we have those who awaken as
sages to serve the gods in times of
hardship we've already witnessed
firsthand how sages can uphold or
restore the sword's power when needed
and historically they've also been known
to pass it down protect it or utilize it
in some way such as when the light sage
rauru repurposed it to serve as a key to
the sacred realm it's even possible that
the sages were directly involved in the
creation of the master sword in some way
something zelda implies in twilight
princess stating that the sword was
created by the wisdom of the ancient
sages of course this does go against the
story of skyward's sword after all zelda
clearly states that hylia created the
goddess sword and was subsequently
forged into the master sword by link and
phi no sage was ever involved in this
process however we do find the insignia
of the six ancient sages inside the
temple of hailia which was built long
before skyloft even existed likely
around the time the war with demise and
his army started so i guess it's
possible that when phi says that hylia
created the goddess sword she simply
means it was crafted by her design but
that the sages are the ones who actually
built it for her the same way the shika
built the gates of time by her design as
well not the best solution perhaps since
there's not a lot of evidence to work
with but at least this way it stays true
to skyward sword while also not
invalidating zelda's quote from twilight
princess either regardless it's clear
that the sages will always have a deep
connection to the master sword in some
way shape or form something we'll
explore further in the later part of the
video as well so in order to restore the
master sword or forge it into something
new while maintaining the same
attributes that allow it to kill a demon
king all these key elements have to be
in place once again problem is breath of
the wild takes place inconceivably long
after skyward sword so long in fact that
even the very existence of ganondorf the
gerudo has faded into a distant legend
that being said it doesn't mean that
hyrule's distant past has been lost or
forgotten entirely on the contrary all
across hyrule we can find remnants of
architecture stories and legends and
ancient symbols that link back to games
like twilight princess ocarina of time
and even as far back as skyward sword
and some of these depictions could be
relevant to the restoration of the
master sword a good place to start would
be by looking at the pedestal the master
sword used to reside in seems only
fitting since this is where it was able
to regenerate itself from the scars of
war to begin with in fact there's a lot
more to the pedestal than the game lets
on directly the structure itself as well
as the rocks surrounding it actually
symbolized the very same elements we
discussed before about the creation of
the master sword as well as maintaining
its power the rock standing at the edge
of the triangle are representations of
din nehru and feror the same three
goddesses whose sacred flames once
tempered the goddess sword into the
master sword the other six rocks
surrounding the pedestal are said to be
representations of various races more
specifically hylian zora gerudo goron
shika and kokiri i think it's safe to
say that these figures are supposed to
symbolize none other than the six sages
notice how there's no representation of
the rito first of all and second the
small rock is referred to as a kokiri as
opposed to a korok a name which the
spirits of the forest haven't gone by
for a very long time this matches
exactly with the sages from ocarina of
time specifically whose races all
correspond to one of the six rocks seen
at the pedestal furthermore we could
make the argument that the three flowers
who are linked to princess zelda
symbolize goddess hylia or maybe the
triangle in the center does seeing as
hylia was once the keeper of the
triforce the deku tree aside from being
a story npc also has a more symbolic
contribution to the story as well the
book states that perhaps by hylia's
design a young cherry tree grew beside
the pedestal of the master sword and
that after an eternity had passed he
eventually became its guardian now the
deku tree has always served as a
guardian of sorts so that's nothing new
but what makes this incarnation of him
different is that this deku tree is a
cherry blossom in japanese culture
cherry blossoms represent the circle of
life and death as well as the concept
that nothing is eternal and must one day
come to an end in the context of the
story this is already a fitting metaphor
for the way the master sword works its
power is something that's borrowed it
does not belong to any one individual
once it served its purpose the hero and
the sword part weighs the hero
eventually dies only for a future
incarnation to take up the sword once
again now cherry blossoms are an
extremely rare occurrence in breath of
the wild's hyrule and it just so happens
that the only other location that
features a cherry blossom tree is on
satori mountain right next to the pond
where satori who is said to be an
ancient sage who died on this mountain
makes his appearance the symbolism
regarding the goddesses and sages
doesn't just stop at the pedestal either
inside the temple of time which
poetically enough once served as the
resting place for the master sword ages
ago we can find a large hylia statue on
the altar in the back surrounded by six
smaller statues then we have the seven
megalithic statues found inside the
gerudo desert massive stoneworks
depicting a group of proud warrior women
gripping a giant sword the inscriptions
on these statues have long since been
translated successfully and spell out
the phrase seven sages which might be a
bit confusing for the newcomers but it's
6 ancient sages plus princess zelda or
if you want to be more technical hylia
additionally our favorite mystery tribe
the zonai also seem to have their own
rendition of the six sages it's a statue
of a boar likely representing ganon
surrounded by six pillars one of the
pillars is toppled over and lies flat on
the ground which is why many believe
that this is depicting the sages from
twilight princess since ganondorf kills
one of the sages in this story as for
the goddesses we have the triforce
symbol in the sanctum the sacred springs
of power wisdom and courage as well as
the three ancient dragons dinro nedra
and farage whose names are all derived
from the golden goddesses as well and of
course hyrule has no shortage of hylia
statues big and small so yes despite the
enormous time gap between breath of the
wild and the older games in the series
many important aspects have survived to
various degrees and the ones i just
listed are still but a fraction but the
question remains if we want to fix the
master sword by repeating a similar
process seen in skyward sword are the
components needed to do this still
accessible in some way or at the very
least a viable substitute i believe so
and in fact it could explain a lot about
the possible direction breath of the
wild 2 is heading towards there's still
a lot of unknowns right now but so far
we've been able to see underground
sections a skyrealm and additionally the
surface of hyrule is being repurposed as
well and i think each of these could be
tied to the various elements needed for
the restoration of the master sword
which to recap is the sacred force
originating from the gods hylia's
blessing and possibly one or more sages
so let's tackle them one by one starting
with the force it's unknown if the
sacred flames still exist in the present
day but if they do the only connection
to them that still persists are the
dragons who in the time of skyward sword
were the protectors of the flames which
is where i believe the sky realm could
come into play we visually see the
dragons disappearing into some sort of
sky portal after which they completely
disappear if the sky is indeed the home
of the dragons it would be the best
place to look for the sacred flames or
something that serves a similar function
next is hylia's blessing which is a bit
of a tricky one as it's not exactly
clear what this so-called blessing
entails when she gives link her blessing
in skyward sword all that really happens
is the hilt unfolds and the blade starts
to glow more brightly but as we can see
in the new footage despite the immense
damage the hilt is still extended so i'm
not sure if the sword even needs to be
blessed again but if it does we have
another problem zelda who carries the
essence of hylia is gone right now we
have no idea what her fate could be this
might be a bit dark but the more i look
into it the more i'm starting to
entertain the possibility that the
yellow orb we see floating in front of
link in the new footage could very well
be zelda's spirit zelda is known to emit
yellow energy not just in breath of the
wild but other games as well and is
implied to be her life force
historically it's also been tied to
light-based weapons as well like the
light arrows which are almost always
obtained through her or she wields the
arrows herself it's kind of hard to
imagine nintendo killing a 17 year old
but then again some of the champions
were pretty young as well as long as you
don't show the gruesome details it's
usually okay not to mention that it
wouldn't be the first time that zelda's
soul became separated from her body in
spirit tracks zelda who by the way is
considerably younger here is technically
dead in a way that isn't to say that
zelda is completely done for again like
in spirit tracks she does turn out okay
in the end and in twilight princess she
sacrifices her life force to save mitna
and here too she somehow manages to come
back again let's also not forget that in
breath of the wild she miraculously
survived being gobbled up and trapped
inside ganon's cocoon for 100 years
without aging a day so yeah i think it's
safe to say that she has some pretty
thick plot armor even if she's quote
unquote dead there's always hope left
for her i'm not sure how it ties into
link's new bracelet but if it's an
artifact that can extract souls or life
force it could explain why zelda's
spirit is inside it either way if
hylia's blessing is needed in some way
to restore the sword we might want to
look into getting her back as well
lastly we have the sages and this is
where i think hyrule's surface and its
underground could be utilized when you
complete the trial of the sword you'll
find seven shika monks surrounding the
master sword on a pedestal in the middle
six of which hold a similar pose to one
of the six sages from ocarina of time
it's not clear if these are the sages of
their time or if they're just imitating
a similar ritual but whatever it is that
they're doing it works and restores the
master sword back to its full potential
not only does it bring back its iconic
glow permanently and boosts its attack
power but it even makes it so that link
himself is now able to hear the voice of
phi resonating from within the sword
the problem is that once link completes
the trial the monks having fulfilled
their purpose pass on to the afterlife
so if the power of the sages is needed
to restore the sword in the sequel then
we'll have to find an alternative either
in the form of new individuals who can
awaken as a sage like an ocarina of time
seeking an audience with their spirits
or perhaps collect something like
materials or artifacts that are linked
to the ancient sages i especially like
the idea of collecting some sort of
elemental material like ore after all
the blade has lost a considerable amount
of its steel which i can imagine has to
be replaced in some way so imagine this
seeing as the pedestal inside korok
forest depicts six different individuals
this could mean that the surface and
hyrule's underground hide ancient
dungeons that are connected to
individual sages azor a dungeon hidden
underwater something related to the
kokiri slash koroks inside a forest
somewhere an ancient gerudo temple maybe
below the arbiter's grounds for example
a rito dungeon either in the sky or in
the snowy mountains something inside
death mountain related to the gorons
which would explain why in the teaser
there's no lava flow anymore and since
the shika have historically been tied to
underground locales something found deep
below the earth would be a good fit for
them and depending on how many sages
will be needed there's always room for
even more something tied to the zonai or
maybe the hylians if we combine this
with the possible trials and obstacles
waiting for us in the skies above the
total dungeon count could be incredible
and with a possible secondary objective
of finding a way to bring back zelda
this game could be absolutely massive
obviously i don't want to overhype the
game too much and risk disappointment
but then again the game has been in
development for close to 6 years now one
of the longest development cycles in
zelda history so i don't think it's a
crime to expect something big still that
doesn't mean my theory is correct and
maybe the story and goals will be vastly
different despite the fact that we're
almost 6 years down the road the amount
of info we have on the game is still
painfully small but i do think that what
we've discussed so far does at least
make sense story wise the little clue
sprinkled throughout the footage as well
as the lore and history from past games
does give us little insights into the
possible story directions especially
when it comes to ganondorf's actions and
motivations they seem to reflect all the
knowledge and experience he's collected
and retained from past failures without
hesitation he swiftly gets rid of the
two most important keys to his defeat
zelda and her ceiling power and the
master sword the second teaser also
hints that something has happened to
korok forest possibly something bad
seeing as the deku tree is missing i
also noticed that this part of the
landscape has an earth or sand texture
which also isn't there in breath the
wild it almost seems as if it's been
uprooted or scorched by some immense
force given what we know about the
forest and the pedestal that lies within
which has the ability to revive the
master sword it would be yet another
brilliant move by ganondorf to swing the
odds in his favor
with all that said let's finally talk
briefly about phi and demise two
entities who also share a close
connection to the master sword so close
in fact that they literally exist inside
it contrary to what some may believe i
don't think that fight or demise are
crucial to the master sword's ability to
vanquish evil especially in the case of
demise since the sword was already able
to slay demons before he got sealed
inside it in fact it's the whole reason
why the sword was made in the first
place to kill him the actual power to
seal darkness likely stems entirely from
the gods as for phi well skyward sword
makes it pretty clear that she was
created with the purpose of offering
guidance to the chosen hero to assist
link in carrying out hylia's plan to
forge a weapon capable of defeating
demise once that plan was realized phi
having served her purpose was quite
literally programmed to go into an
everlasting slumber inside the master
sword as such i also don't believe that
her purpose was to subdue demise after
he got sealed inside the sword she
clearly states that her very being her
consciousness is fading away she never
says that she's going in there to keep
demise from breaking free in fact empire
is the one who stands guard for
thousands of years to ensure that this
doesn't happen i know a lot of people
would love to see demise's comeback and
even i wouldn't mind seeing him at least
being referenced in some way but i also
think the part about demise being inside
the master sword is a bit misunderstood
it's not comparable to say ganondorf
being sealed inside the sacred realm or
twilight realm only to break free again
someday demise was killed both in body
and in spirit all that's left of him are
his remains which according to impa have
already started to decay moments after
his defeat that was many many ages ago
so it's hard to believe that anything
physical remains of him at all at this
point and it doesn't have to demise's
legacy is far worse and far more
effective than that his curse is what
set into motion the endless rebirth of
demons born from his hatred one could
even make the argument that in a way
ganondorf himself is an extension of
demise that isn't to say that phi's
existence within the sword serves no
future purpose at all after all she does
say may we meet again in another life
and in breath of the wild we saw the
first signs that fai's consciousness is
reawakening yet again offering guidance
this time to zelda in an attempt to save
the hero's life so who knows maybe she
will have an even bigger role to play in
the sequel we do see a faint blue glow
on the hilt right before link pulls the
sword from its sheet so i'm willing to
believe that she's still in there and as
far as seeking out the means to fix the
sword phi would be the one being who
would know how after all she was heavily
involved in its creation it would be
amazing if we catch a glimpse of her
again especially since traditionally old
companions never make a comeback in
zelda games
let's conclude the video with some
alternatives to today's theory options
which i haven't mentioned so far because
they made less sense to me than my main
theory or i found them to be a bit too
far-fetched the first is time travel
obviously if time travel does exist in
breath of the wild too it would probably
be the easiest way to fix things going
back to before ganondorf destroys the
sword traveling to the age of skyward
sword and reforging it in the sacred
flames there or heck just go to age of
calamity's timeline and bring back that
version of the master sword the problem
i have with this is that i simply don't
see enough evidence of time travel in
the sequel just yet something i'll make
a future video on i also think that
after skyward sword hd and age of
calamity's time travel plot it would be
best not to repeat the same thing again
not every zelda game has to have time
travel to create an interesting
narrative next is the triforce which
wasn't present in breath the wild well
not really anyway if link can somehow
manage to obtain the full triforce he
would be able to wish for the master
sword's revival but i think it goes
without saying that this would be a bit
of a weird way to go about the narrative
i mean if link would have the full
triforce he wouldn't need the master
sword anymore now would he you could
simply wish for ganondorf's obliteration
and that's that it also doesn't really
match with the current setup why
emphasize the broken master sword like
this if we're not gonna use it to fight
ganondorf in some way could he at least
obtain the triforce of courage yeah sure
but that doesn't change the fact that
the master sword is busted the triforce
of courage is not enough to defeat
ganondorf maybe earning the triforce of
courage will be a secondary objective in
the story like in the wind waker but i
don't see link wielding the full
triforce unless he does it after he's
already killed ganondorf maybe as a way
to undo the damage he's done to hyrule
and its people similar to a link to the
past lastly we have the by far most
awesome scenario but also the most
far-fetched and that is that link needs
to go in search of the four sword i mean
ganondorf has been defeated by the four
sword once before it's one of only a few
blades in the zelda universe that can
somewhat match the properties of the
master sword i don't see a whole lot of
evidence that suggests that this will be
the case say for maybe the eye symbol on
link's new shield which does have a
pretty strong resemblance to vati but
that's about it you know what would be
cool if we had to fuse the four sword
and the master sword together creating
the master iv sword and to compensate
ganondorf teams up with vati then in the
final boss fight they do one of those
dragon ball z fusion dances together and
they become vati ganon or vanon but of
course link can now split into four so
he's like and then zelda and mitna show
up and they do a little fusion dance of
their own and become one entity as well
which should have happened in twilight
princess by the way fannin then summons
the moon from a juror's mask and darth
vader and legolas show up and they're
like
alright i think that's enough internet
for today thank you so much for watching
the video be sure to let me know how you
think the story will unfold by leaving a
comment below a big shout out goes to my
hard-working mods on discord to samuel
who created the artwork scene in the
final section of the video and my
patreons and channel members i've got a
few new faces to announce so please say
hello to buffy v wavery james west
shizobro 100 zelda vicinity free mika
vance didachu and rose red17 thank you
all so much for the support and that is
all for now this is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
you